[Music]
hello and welcome to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter lovell
what explains joe biden's sudden drop in
the polls as a candidate he promised to
return to some form of normality however
his current standing with the public is
anything but
is his agenda the problem maybe he's not
as likable as he once seemed
he is in trouble and so is this party
[Music]
crosstalking biden's poll numbers i'm
joined by against ed martin in
washington he is president of the
national conservative organization
phyllis schaffler eagles as well as
co-author of the conservative case for
trump in las vegas we have laura fink
she is founder and ceo of bravo
communications and a democratic
strategist and in gainesville we cross
to richard boris he is director of big
data poll all right crosstalk rules in
effect that means you can jump anytime
you want and i always appreciate it
richard let me go to you because you're
a pollster um can you explain to us to
our audience very briefly what in the
world is going on because i'm calling
this program sudden pole death because
that's what it looks like go ahead
richard
yeah i mean generally speaking uh you
know peter joe biden does not have
something that both barack obama and
donald j trump had which were a base of
support that loved both of these men and
it was very difficult for their poll
numbers to really take a dive because
there was always a group that very much
supported them george w bush had it with
evangelicals he didn't lose them until
the second term with the recession and
the war uh right now joe biden just
didn't have that strongly approved base
of support and we're seeing the bottom
fall out and it really is coming from
independence democrats they show some
leakage but it's independence and it's
the third party voters that generally
most people think put him over in those
battleground states okay laura react to
what richard just said there is that
true do you agree with that go ahead
well i think we have to look at when the
poll numbers started declining because
there's no arguing that they are they
are running parallel to how americans
feel about the economy it started with
sort of the summer of sadness with the
surge of the delta variant and even
though we see since 2019 stock
portfolios with the s p 500 up 30 home
values are up and most american
households are doing better than they
did prior to the pandemic there is this
feeling because they're going and seeing
the price of milk and the price of gas
that things aren't aren't going as well
i think as you start to see an inflation
subside the supply chain uh problems
fixed there you're going to start to see
that perception of the economy uh get a
little bit better and joe biden's
approval ratings will improve as a
result and and we do see 65
uh drop in unemployment since with the
american rescue plan with the vaccines
getting distributed we're now at about
five percent this is out of line with
how americans are feeling again because
of those day-to-day costs but i think as
those subside uh you're going to see joe
biden's uh poll numbers rise again and
then again obviously if he passes that
infrastructure bill that pair of bills
he'll be doing better as well okay let
me go to ed and watch it okay
okay it could be all about the economy
but and is it about is is it about the
person as well because um some of the
polls i've been looking at over the last
few months the trust uh question he's
taking a hit there do you trust the
president okay and that is a very
general however you want to interpret
trust here is it how much of it is it
about the man himself go ahead ed
well look i think it's all about the man
and look we talk about barack obama
donald trump i mean these two barack
obama was sort of a legislator but he
mostly was a a guy an ambitious
politician donald trump a businessman
you know look joe biden is a senator uh
when afghanistan happened he went to a
senate hideaway uh camp david that's
what senators do if you're a senator no
one can tell you look joe manchin is
living this uh cinema christian cinema
is living this no one can tell you what
to do how to vote where to show who to
talk to nothing and joe biden just is
doing whatever he wants and he's failing
at it afghanistan's a disaster the
border's a disaster yesterday we have
excuse me not yesterday late earlier
this week we have a a document put out a
national gender strategy look it may
that may please some people in the in
the ivory towers or in the activist camp
but the reality is the american people
are looking up and they're saying we've
got inflation gas prices up the border
is you know poros we've got a drug
problem people are dying from fentanyl
and and joe biden is incapable of being
in charge i'm not all his policies are
not as unpopular as he is he looks
absolutely weak he looks like he can't
get his arms around things he does town
halls with anderson cooper and he says
freedom come on man freedom everybody is
scared of covet if they say they're not
they're lying and we haven't figured out
we have a guy that's kind of just
mocking half the country so it's not
going to get better if the economy gets
better right now i'm in the commonwealth
of virginia in about four days we're
going to see that terry mcauliffe a joe
biden look alike an insider forever is
going to lose for governor it looks like
and and at that point all
biden's priorities are out the window
and we're just you know nursing
ourselves towards the 2022 elections
okay laura because you're the odd man
you're the odd man out on the panel so
i'm going to go back to laura go ahead
in las vegas
look we can i think my colleague needs
to put his pom-poms down for a minute
because we've gone from talking about
realities
to talking about cheerleading for what
what he may want now the reality is
biden's poll numbers were really solid
right up until the beginning of summer
people approved and trusted him because
of his actions on the pandemic the
environmentals are what have changed
primarily and they are you otherwise you
wouldn't see it tracking directly with
how americans feel about the economy now
as as it is true independents are
weakening and even he's lost some soft
support from democrats all of that
changes with the passage of
infrastructure bills one of them heavily
bipartisan something that he promised on
the campaign trail he has to deliver and
he will deliver as we'll see coming up
in the week or two ahead those bills are
progressing nicely and the other thing
is we've been talking about the sausage
which also doesn't help him because
we're not talking about those popular
issues like child care and elder care
help for parents uh infrastructure
rebuilding our ports that where we see
clogs right now because of the supply
chain all of those things are going to
help buy these pool numbers and give
democrats something to talk about right
now republicans want to defend the
wealthy and they want to protect
billionaires from having taxes raised
and you know what across the board even
among their own bills
come on man okay hold it hold it
everybody
okay hold it let me go to richard here
you said a lot laura let richard react
okay okay go ahead i wouldn't let yeah
i would have let laura finish your
thought uh you know because
it did it would have sounded like a
until then honestly it did sound a bit
like a wish list and i'd really like to
just get back to the numbers we've been
tracking joe biden since he was
inaugurated and what was said before
about having solid numbers was we we
called him artificial his approval
rating basically was artificial he came
in with high numbers based on
artificial being that he it was driven
by coveted approval it was not driven by
high marks generally across the board on
other issues he nine months of tracking
and he never scored high marks on other
issues he came in on what was said
it
please let richard speak let richard
speak go ahead look we predicted this
for six months out once his covet
approval started to fall it was going to
drag down the rest of his overall
approval because generally people were
telling us they approved generally of
the job he was doing because of coven on
no other issue from foreign policy to
the economy to immigration from health
care crime public safety nothing did he
ever score high marks especially not for
an inaugurally inaugurated president he
made an impossible to keep campaign
promise which was to get a pandemic in
order better than the prior president
and once that did not happen he began to
fall before afghanistan i need to make
this clear he began to fall before
afghanistan and our registered voter
economic confidence index is at the
lowest level it has ever been and i'll
end with this that what is important to
note about that index is that people
post shut down and pre-or uh biden
taking the oath of office they were
optimistic that the economy was going to
rebound we do the six-month outlook and
now we're we're six months eight months
nine months down the road and it didn't
happen so we have to keep in touch you
know a little bit can some legislative
achievements help him a little bit
but
peter
i missed that laura what did laura say
i was just saying unemployment's down 55
it's now at five percent like i'm just
wondering you know nobody cares yeah but
let's not people nobody cares people
didn't fall for methodological gimmicks
people didn't fall for the
methodological gimmicks at the bureau of
labor statistics under barack obama
either that's why we got donald trump it
is the quality jobs lawyer not the
candidate hang on richard laura hang on
we have a third guest and his name is ed
ted weigh in go ahead ed well let me say
peter i mean look i if i can just make a
short list a litany of biden's failures
even the obama ethics czar says that 100
what hunter biden is doing selling his
uh finger paints is wrong we now know
that the hunter biden laptop was true
and it was hidden by big tech a lot of
independents are looking up and saying
what is all this lying we're getting
fauchi has been shown to say one thing
one day another thing other day i'm not
saying it's all his fault i'm saying
this is the reality gas prices are
through the roof based on the policies
based on the wait a second based on the
policies of biden biden couldn't figure
out how to get out of afghanistan and we
lost 13 men and women there at the end
it's just a litany you can say you want
and by the way his great bipartisan bill
is dead it's not passing nothing he said
he was going to do is doing it and what
is he doing susan rice and lisa monaco
are rolling out a gender strategy
and hoping that we can have our
passports with x instead of male or
female the american people hang on
hang on everybody i knew this was going
to be a bit rocko's here laura it's your
turn go ahead oh let's talk about the
gender strategy for a minute we see a
she session women on the sidelines why
because of a lack of access to child
care if women do not rejoin the economy
the economy does not thrive biden has a
plan for that and to speak to the fact
that you're calling me
you're bringing the debt down one moment
please you're bringing the death now on
biden's strategy he's already gotten a
bipartisan infrastructure deal past the
senate something all y'all said that he
couldn't do and now he and nancy pelosi
are on the press precipice of delivering
in partnership with conservative
democrats joe manchin and kristin cinema
and and that's going to give them
something to tout all through the
midterms and i think what you're not
hearing from my friends here is the
weaknesses of the republican party when
you pull on republicans they say they
are the defenders of the wealthy and
obstructionists to anything biden wants
to do if biden starts having a
conversation about those issues and you
get some stuff done on the legislative
front that's where the compensation is
going to be during the midterms and
republicans are going to have to account
for the fact that all they do all right
i'm going to jump in here we have to go
to a short break and after that short
break we'll continue our discussion on
biden's poll numbers stay with rt
[Music]
welcome back to crosstalk where all
things are considered i'm peter level
remind you we're discussing biden's poll
numbers
[Music]
okay let's go back to richard and
gainesville i got a bone to pick with
you my friend
you guys got the polls wrong in 2016 you
got the polls wrong in 2020 so i mean
make your case my friend
well i didn't and that's the only case i
can make
right when it comes down to it track
record matters uh we were the odd men
out bold time took a lot of heat for it
but you know the polling industry no
doubt peter's had a lot of challenges
you know we try to be a voice in uh in
that conversation about how to make
things better uh unfortunately you know
what fortunately we're making some
headway uh but not not enough but i
think that uh over time it's a brave new
world out there there are different ways
to reach different people and uh though
you know i my hope is we'll catch up but
in the end all i can say for myself is
uh i didn't
that's it
okay good all right ed let me go back to
you i mean it's already been alluded to
in the program here um
um you know there was the perception
that joe is this good old guy from
delaware you know but you know he's been
around for you know a couple hundred
years in the senate you know a nice guy
bipartisan guy but i mean is that the
perception a lot of people have of him
now because he's very hectoring um he's
losing patience with the the electorate
here i mean he's his tone is very
different than other presidents he
doesn't have a lot of patience it
appears okay i don't know if that if
that's a function of his age his
temperament and all that but it's a
different
hang on hang on i'm going to ed here
we're seeing somebody a little bit
different than what we were sold go
ahead ed
yeah i mean three quick observations on
that number one i i do think to to give
him some credit i'm not sure how any
president is going to ever be a two-term
president in this world we live in
because the intensity of the coverage
the the way it works out and i don't
think biden was cut out for this moment
you know trump was whether you liked him
or not he was fast into the social media
and all that so i think that's one
disadvantage the second one which will
make laura's head explode but no one is
willing to say it and i will he's
clearly mentally not able to do this job
i mean my wife is a geriatrics physician
and one of the things you get as people
deteriorate in the end of their life is
these bursts of anger the way he acts is
not if you watched him on the anderson
cooper town hall and you go back and
look for the video five years ago it's
obvious deterioration i'm not blaming
him i'm saying a 78 year old man in this
kind of intense job it's it's harder to
do the 55 year old men get gray and
remember george w and obama how
different they look last observation on
polling versus what i call trolling i
staff a booth at the my farmer's market
near my house every saturday morning for
four hours the republican party in
fairfax county virginia commonwealth and
over the last about six weeks we've seen
now we have an election next week uh uh
next week in in the commonwealth of
virginia for governor but the intensity
and the number of people that are
talking about how badly biden and the
democrats are doing it's just ticked up
now it's a republican tent but it's
northern virginia and a lot of the
republican tent people would tell me
they hated trump and all that so but
you're just feeling a very different
thing than we felt before and i think
again to richard's point forget about
the hardcore democrats and the hardcore
republicans it's not going anywhere the
rest of the country though whatever that
number is they're looking up and seeing
this president isn't up for the job the
vice president's not up for the job and
the country the basics i didn't even get
to my list the supply chain we can't get
to get the supply chain problem solved
you're telling me that we can't figure
out a way to get more trucks to the port
of la to get the stuff off the i'm at
the supermarket last night they're out
of crackers i got sick people at home i
need crackers they're out of crackers
this again the american people and not
the hardcore dams or harco republicans
they look up and say something's wrong
here and they are putting that on biden
laura is is is joe biden a drag on the
party at this point as we go into the
midterms
oh lord have mercy let me start
no joe biden's gonna be fine joe biden
was in virginia stumping there i think
you know i'm gonna make ed's head
explode by talking about two things one
by his argument that because biden is is
more harassable
than he's he's declining as a as a
senior um
not what i said
by that argument we would all be
indicted as losing our minds just on the
basis of our last segment so i will say
this oh come on laura
he's having imaginary conversations with
rabbis he never met with during meetings
he never went to come on let's be real
uh look can i get back to the
independence peter hang on let laura
finish no no no no no no
i want to be fair laura's the odd man
out and she needs time
fair time for everyone laura
it's fine it's
fine go
oh i'm gonna go now okay let's talk
about pete buda judge single-handedly
being responsible for a global pandemic
that is affecting every country on the
globe that's happening
listen i'm just gonna finish maybe one
to five sentences if that's okay so
people to judge can't be blamed for that
and biden has the the ports in long
beach responsible for forty percent of
our freight operating operating 24 7.
we're seeing the limits of what
presidents can do not what joe biden can
do and and i would say this the talk in
virginia i'm gonna make heads ed's head
explode one more time by agreeing with
them that the reality is that they're
that that trump supporters are angry and
they have anger on their side which is
what he's hearing in the republican tent
they have that energy that's what
democrats have to contend with trump now
being off the stage off of social media
that energy has been taken away from the
democratic base that's the challenge
that they have going into the midterms
which will be solved by bringing an army
and truckloads of accomplishments with
them which they're on the on the
precipice of doing uh with this
legislative agenda and biden's economic
agenda moving through congress this week
okay richard um lbj had his great
society but it didn't help him when he
was considering to run to 68. i mean i
don't i don't buy this i don't buy this
i mean
people don't vote on history people
don't vote for politicians based on
bills there's no correlation go ahead
richard anything yeah that's absolutely
true and fdr and fdr lost tremendous
support after the midterms when he
passed the great uh the new deal so part
of this is just history that laura and
democrats are battling against you know
republicans they were they were late to
acknowledge it too before 2018. you know
they wanted that election to be about
healthcare peter and what's going on in
virginia is that they were trying to
stay on the pandemic and medicaid
expansion message and it didn't happen
it didn't work the top issues in that
election are economy and jobs uh taxes
inflation and then education now has
soared to number two going to those
independents and this is bran these are
brand new numbers joe biden won the
state of virginia 54-44 the problem
democrats have is they they have lost 10
and and it's getting larger every day at
least 10
since uh november 2020 he won
independence over donald trump 57-38 the
electorate was not
exceedingly democratic it was only d
plus two mcauliffe cannot afford a d
plus two because right now those very
same voters approve of joe biden by only
and they are breaking to younken by 11
and that is
climbing that has been climbing in our
two day rolling average so democrats
need a turnout advantage on tuesday that
they
that they did not get since ralph
northam beat ed gillespie going and that
was a good democratic year right now
we're going into a challenging uh year
for democrats and younkin is winning the
very same group of voters who backed joe
biden over donald trump last november
this is the problem the real this is
earth we're back now on planet earth and
this is the problem and it's it's just
it's just history
today
hang on let me go to there
i just want to add here republicans
thought taxes would help them too and it
didn't yeah that's my point okay
ed you're you're in the commonwealth of
virginia please explain to us what is
prioritize the issues going into this
governor's race here what and and to
what degree are the culture wars flaming
both sides go ahead ed
well i would say that i would say always
it's jobs in the economy and even though
northern virginia is insulated by the
the swamp in terms of jobs there's a
sense again gas prices are up the
supermarket prices are people aren't
feeling confident and you know to
laura's point it's kind of funny because
you watch wall street is still having
records right but it's that's how people
feel i'd say the number the intent the
most intense issue is is the education
issue and it's it's not really crt it's
this it's this notion that somehow
parents have said we want a chance and
mcauliffe i i had someone say this will
really make lord house i had someone say
the most infamous comment since
legitimate rape by todd aiken was terry
mcauliffe saying parents shouldn't have
a say over education which is what he
said at the debate two weeks ago and for
a change the democrats are paying a
price for early voting here we have
early voting and moms are going to the
polls saying what and yunkan is standing
there saying i'll spend more money on
schools i'll do more things so education
is second i would say now the problem
for the democrats and laura did put this
right they're running ads saying trump
trump trump trying to get people to
think about trump it's just i don't
think it's working you know my my wife
turned to me in the day when there was a
trump junk in his trump ad which said
trump's a businessman yunkan's a
businessman they both want to take over
and help their friends she said to me is
that supposed to hurt him i don't think
that the trump trump trump thing works
but but the old-fashioned caveat and
this is richard's point every party in
power thinks we'll just tell him what we
did and they'll come out for us right
now obama's in richmond four or five or
six days ago trying to get the
african-american vote out because if
they vote 82 for mcauliffe instead of 88
mcauliffe loses and that's the problem
they have right now and they're banging
the abortion drum the democrats are
trying to get the uh you know the people
that care about that issue to come it's
not really what's moving right now as
far as we can see but we still have you
know we still have to wonder how the
election will go we have some big
counties fairfax and others that are
going to have to count the votes and uh
you know there's a lot going on
laura is is joe biden a progressive what
kind i mean what is his politics okay
because i mean he's an old
segregationist and now he's a
progressive in the white house can you
explain that to me
good job peter wow
going back he's a segregationist now he
was he was he was he was search the
other side good job there that's a
that's a republican attack ad right here
you heard it here um listen joe biden is
a moderate joe biden is a bipartisan no
biden has a long history for you to look
at where that is the case and and so i
think one of the challenges and we heard
it with with respect to the virginia
governor's race one of the challenges in
that race you wouldn't know it by
talking to my colleagues but um that
race is neck and neck that race will be
very close one way or the other yes it's
of the republicans um and you know terry
mcauliffe does need to like hone in on a
particular message but the ground troops
are out and democrats are doing
everything they can everybody from
barack obama to stacey abrams and and
the fact is democrats aren't just aren't
a unilateral party that's motivated by a
single issue and they don't have that
anger advantage in this election which
means they have to appeal to things like
a woman's right to choose they have to
talk about the environment they have to
talk about a multi-pronged approach
that's a harder job and a harder lift
especially with those consumer numbers
where they are right now but but the
fact that terry mcauliffe is still neck
and neck i think speaks to the fact that
they've got a real shot at winning this
and and certainly 12 months from now at
holding that house and senate okay well
the fact that young ken is even in the
race tells us everything we need to know
about virginia possibly um the state of
american politics and maybe how people
feel about joe biden that's all the time
we have want to thank my guests in
washington las vegas and in gainesville
and thanks to our viewers for watching
us here at rt see you next time and
remember crosstalk rules
[Music]